jojo was geht hier soll marx und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
legen wir direkt los ich habe einen hack
für pokémon go gefunden ich weiß nicht
wie es euch geht aber ich persönlich
fand das hacken in spielen schon immer
mega interessant ich habe niemals selbst
gehackt um irgendwelche vorteile zu
verschaffen und anderen leuten damit
irgendwie auf der nase rumtanzen oder so
sondern ich habe es einfach gemacht weil
ich krass fand wie lustig es ist die
barrieren die einem so ein spiel
auferlegt umgehen ich weiß nicht viel
von euch bestimmt aufgefallen dass mein
iphone jailbreak ist und das ist halt
alles weil ich halt super gerne rum
experimentiere und gerne über die
grenzen die einem durch irgendwas
gesetzt werden hinausgehe
so jetzt habe ich ein pokémon ball weg
gefunden diese heck ist nicht so krass
dass ihr die irgendwie jedes pokémon auf
dieser welt anzeigt oder du dir
aussuchen kann ist welche pokémon zu
gefangen hast sondern dieser heck
ermöglicht ihr ganz einfach herum zu
laufen ohne zu laufen sozusagen durch
tippen auf den bildschirm dich in
pokemon golf fortzubewegen
so und jetzt sagen viele das ist doch
nicht der sinn der sache und teilweise
stimmt ja auch zu aber ist es der sinn
der sache im auto in der stadt rom zu
fahren und poker stopps abzufahren wenn
wir ehrlich sind auch nicht also ich
finde den harmlos eigentlich den hexer
super nützlich für leute die sagen immer
irgendwie zu hause bleiben müssten weil
sie krank sind oder was auch immer und
keine angst ich werde mich zeigen würde
installiert sondern ich zeig euch nur
wie das ding funktioniert also nehmen
wir mal an gesetzen hier in unserem haus
überall sein fokus tops ihr seht ihr
schon in der seite da haben wir einmal
den speed button da kann man zwei mal
drauf klicken dann wird es zu zwei mal
speed noch mal drauf drücken da wird zu
viel speed das bestimmt dann später die
geschwindigkeit mit der man laufen kann
dapd das ist das haupt diesem hack curry
und man kann das ganz einfach aktivieren
man drückt drauf und dann kann man
loslaufen dann probier wir das ganze mal
aus da vorne sind poker stopps wir
können jetzt nicht hin laufen weil wir
gerade dieses video aufnehmen und vom pc
sitzen aber keine angst leute wir können
das ganze sie machen wir drücken hier
drauf und laufen auf den pokerstop zu
die steuerung ist relativ schwierig weil
der ding teil der charaktere sich nur
nach norden bewegen kann aber wir laufen
jetzt darauf zu und jetzt sind wir hier
beim pokerstop.de aktivieren das
und können sie das teil holen also so
funktioniert das ganze ist es super
simpel und eigentlich ist es halt nur
ein ersatz fürs rumlaufen also es ist
kein ultra krankes ding wie du irgendwie
diese coins hecken kannst oder so aber
ja also ich zeige ja nochmal die
steuerung aus der hand ihr aktiviert
halt dieses tepco kann setzt ihr den
speed fest mit dem ihr laufen volt und
könnt ganz einfach loslaufen wo in dem
ihr halt so ein bisschen herumprobiert
wir in die richtige richtung läuft halt
einfach okay da vorne sind pokerstop
soll möchte ich gern hin
dann drückt hier immer so ein bisschen
weiter weiter und dann seid ihr halt
beim pokerstars und den easy abfahren
wie auch gesehen hab ich habe mir extra
nen account dafür gemacht um dieses
video aufzunehmen weil ich hab halt
herrnburg dass mein account auf dem ich
normal spiele und auf dem direkt nicht
installiert ist irgendwie gewann führt
weil selbstverständlich leute wenn ihr
sowas macht riskiert ihr gewand zu
werden es gibt zwar noch keine meldungen
darüber dass irgendwelche leute gebannt
wurden aber es kann passieren so und
logischerweise könnt ihr euch hat auch
um bewegen und pokemon fangen die sich
in der nähe befinden wo ich habe zb
bisasam in der nähe hat betz und hier
sind zum beispiel 2 aufgetaucht
und dann könnt ihr ganz normal auf die
pokémon draufklicken und die dinger
fangen und die dinger fangen so einfach
geht das also ihr könnt rumlaufen ohne
zu laufen das ist halt der ganze sinn
von diesem hack das geht halt
ultraschnell wenn ihr das ganze auf vier
mal geschwindigkeit macht kühl auf
diesmal auf diese pokerstop welle der
liebe hin und probieren uns einfach hier
vor ein paar zu holen und dann könnt ihr
einfach draufklicken und kerstin
pokerstop und nächster pokerstop.de
nächster pokerstop checke ich persönlich
nutze das teil nicht aber wie gesagt ich
fand zeit ultra interessant so als
pokémon rauskam habe ich geschaut wie
pokemon black und hape gesucht gibt es
schon heck und dann habe ich halt diesen
hack gefunden auf reddit ja ich fand es
super interessant und deshalb dachte ich
mir bevor ihr euch selbst das ding
installieren müsst falls ihr genauso
neugierig seid wie ich zeige ich euch
das mal ich lauf gerade zum beispiel auf
zwei lockt modul dazu und wir können
einfach dahin laufen nicht zu sagen
dahin sitzen weil wir eigentlich hier
sitzen die sich schon hier sind überall
pokémon die können jetzt ganz easy
fangen und ja
so funktioniert der hack das video ist
es relativ kurz gehalten okay es liegt
auch gerade wieder super des videos
relativ kurz gehalten ich hoffe mal fand
das video informativ falls ja das doch
ein leichter und ja das was von heute
macht es gut und bis zum nächsten mal